So one of the great things
about being an entrepreneur
is that you don't have to pretend
to be someone you're not.
You can build the culture around
things that you care about,
build your own value system.
You don't have to pretend
to be a suit in an office.
The funny thing is that I don't
really feel very successful.
I know I've been lucky
to build a company,
and that company got sold
for a lot of money.
But in my own head,
I still beat myself up and I think,
"Come on! You haven’t actually
contributed something to the world.
You've got to do something
that's more meaningful,
make sure we don't screw
up the next 10, 20 years."
I think that's quite a good tension,
if you can make sure that
you channel it in a positive way
and not something that
whirs away in your head
and feels like a negative thought.
Lastminute.com was really one of the
first e-commerce companies in Europe.
We had to convince people,
back in 1998,
that people were going to
buy stuff
with their credit cards
on the internet.
Can you imagine that?
Isn't there an awful lot of pressure
on you now?
Because this has become
a major company.
There's always been a pressure on us,
but it's no worse than it's been
for the last couple of years.
It's so hard when
you're in a start-up
because your personality
is part of how you market
and communicate.
But if I look back, I think I put
myself out there a bit too much.
When the stock market collapsed
and our share price went from
£5.35 to about 19p
I got a lot of attention
in the media,
and I got a lot
of handwritten letters.
I got 3,000 letters from
people writing to me
telling me I was an awful
person for taking their money.
I was naive
in dealing with the media,
and I was naive a bit in thinking
we could attract all this attention
and not meet the
consequences of that.
So, be yourself,
build things around
the values that you have,
but hold a little bit back.
So in 2004, I just left my company,
Lastminute.com,
and I was taking a few months off.
And I was in Morocco
with my new boyfriend
and I fell out of a car.
I wasn't wearing a seatbelt,
we skidded off the road.
I broke 28 bones and I had a stroke.
I had to then spend pretty much
the next two years in hospital,
and the next
probably two years after that
in hospital in my own house
recovering from that
cataclysmically bad event.
I was pretty out of it
for a long time in hospital
but I had decided I was going
to start another business
before I had the accident,
called Lucky Voice.
It's a karaoke business,
and the guy I was going
to start the business with
used to come to me in hospital
and start showing me kind of
designs and drawings,
and all the things
we were going to do.
I was completely high on morphine
and I don't really remember
anything that I said to him.
But it actually was
pretty important for me
because trying to rebuild your body,
but at the same time you want
to get your brain back a bit too.
And I didn't want to be
slowly wasting away,
just focusing on
whether I could stand up.
I'd built an online
e-commerce business -
pretty much the most
techy thing you could do,
and then all of a sudden it's
building bars in the real world.
But I think being imaginative
in how you build your life
and your career is really rewarding
and actually quite important
in terms of how we build
resilience as human beings.
I am the worst karaoke singer
you can possibly imagine.
I pick things which
you can't really massacre,
and now post the accident I often
sing Elton John, I'm Still Standing,
for obvious reasons.
Inspiration and things can come
from all kinds of surprising places.
I've never really had a plan,
don't tell anyone.
But I would really urge you
to be open-minded
about how you build your career
and about opportunities.
So always take the call, always be
opportunistic, always be open-minded,
and talk to people and meet people
and don't feel like you have
to have a set way of doing things.
The incredible thing about
being an entrepreneur
and understanding
a bit about technology
is that you see how quickly
things can change
and how innovation is possible.
You don't have to be the person
doing the coding,
you can be the person working
in any aspect of technology.
So don't shy away from technology
because it can help us
solve the big problems.
That cat!